- It's a video of a beluga whale
and these kids at an aquarium.
(upbeat brass instruments)
- My mom almost
exclusively shares pictures
of dogs and cats that need adoption.
- Children hearing a favorite song
and dancing mid football.
- Fresh Pug of Bel Air.
- Chicken soup recipe,
and then we've got a dog.
- Book awards.
Who doesn't love book awards?
- It's a kitty cat that needs a home.
And a dog that needs a home.
And there's a cat that needs a home.
This is exactly my mom.
My mom has cared more about her animals
than her children for as
long as I can remember.
- A very rare video of Helen
Keller with Andy Sullivan.
(laughs) Mom.
- That squirrel got its head
stuck in a Halloween decoration
and terrified the neighborhood.
That is terrifying.
- My mom's digital presence
is basically her in real life,
but just the most effusive, sentimental,
extreme version of it.
- She literally shares
something every hour,
and tags me every time.
In everything she shares.
(upbeat brass instruments)